[Music]
on this thursday night russia now
claiming control of mariupol the west
says not so fast there is no evidence
yet that mary paul is completely fall
who is still trapped in the city the
weapons on the way and russia's newest
sanctions against canada on the path of
healing we can't change history but we
definitely can change the future what
happened when the manitoba metis
federation met the pope
what do you get the woman who has
everything it was done in a spirit of of
love and gratitude a canadian artist's
gift for the monarch
plus smart cookies with separation
anxiety and i think we went through
about 20 boxes of oreos a sweet batch of
experiments to break apart the mystery
of a beloved snack
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are watching events in ukraine
closely again tonight in particular the
besieged port city of mariopol russia
claims it is now in control there though
that is being disputed the mayor accuses
russian troops of hiding war crimes of
picking up the bodies of civilians
killed in the streets and dumping them
in mass graves these satellite images
show what appear to be trenches of newly
dug mass graves next to an old cemetery
just outside mary opal the mayor
estimates more than 20 thousand
residents have been killed since russian
forces began attacking
the u.s today promised more weapons to
ukraine 800 million dollars in lethal
aid
this package includes heavy artillery
weapons
dozens of howitzers and 144 000 rounds
of ammunition to go with those howitzers
it also includes more tactical drones
president biden says the weapons will be
sent directly to the front lines it is
obvious ukrainians need the weapons
right now
jackson proskow has our top story
tonight
these are the lucky ones 79 people just
three busloads able to escape the siege
of mariupol
the russians were bombing us from day
one says this woman they are demolishing
everything just erasing it
yet for a second straight day attempts
at a large-scale civilian convoy out of
the city failed ukraine blamed russian
forces
the russian onslaught has decimated the
ukrainian port city once home to 400
thousand people
ukraine's president zelinski estimated
120 thousand civilians are still trapped
the situation is bad he said
in moscow president vladimir putin
claimed mariupol is now firmly in
russian control before the cameras he
then ordered his defense minister not to
attack the sprawling steel mill where
thousands of ukrainian soldiers and
civilians remain holed up instead putin
insisted on a tight blockade effectively
sealing them in
invite all those who have not yet laid
down their arms to do so he said as he
promised to guarantee their safety
for the women and children trapped
underground in the maze of tunnels
conditions are bleak
if it weren't for the ukrainian soldiers
we'd have no food says this mother it's
questionable whether he does control
mario paul one thing for sure we know
about maripo
he should allow humanitarian carters to
let people on that steel mill and other
places are buried under rubble to get
out
in washington president joe biden
announced the swift deployment of more
u.s military aid long-range weapons
meant to help ukraine beat back the
russian offensive now focused in the
country's east the u.s will also provide
more direct funding to the ukrainian
government and a program to help welcome
refugees to the u.s we're in a critical
window now of time where
that they're going to set the stage for
the next phase of this war
as they have throughout the eight week
long conflict ukraine civilians will
continue to face the brunt of what comes
next
a war with no end in sight
jackson prosko global news washington
russia's foreign ministry has banned 61
more canadians from entering the country
five canadian premiers have been added
to the kremlin so-called stop list along
with the mayors of toronto and ottawa
and several federal government and
military officials a handful of canadian
journalists are also banned from russia
along with the heads of three media
organizations in the country the kremlin
also sanctioned 29 more americans today
it calls this a response to the
ever-expanding anti-russian sanctions
imposed by the west
police are searching for a suspected
arsonist in victoria after the home of
the ukrainian priest was set on fire the
priest and his family were asleep inside
the home next door to the ukrainian
catholic church in victoria his wife
says she witnessed someone pouring gas
through the mail slot and the flames
were already spreading fast by the time
the family got downstairs the priest
managed to run out the back door she and
their three young daughters were forced
to jump from the second floor window the
priest says his family has never known
to be the target of threats
this was a shock
and especially that it's kind of it's
it wasn't an accident as you can tell it
wasn't like someone just
oops it happened uh sorry about that
it's someone
uh
it was targeted for whatever reasons
police are looking into whether there's
a connection between the fire and the
family's ukrainian heritage and are
asking the public for any information
another delegation from canada was at
the vatican today meeting with pope
francis to tell him in person about the
terrible legacy of residential schools
the manitoba metis federation made their
own trip to rome separate from the
larger delegation of indigenous leaders
and elders who visited last month as
marnie blunt reports the pope asked for
forgiveness
we can't change history but we
definitely can change the future
hope
revitalization and forgiveness
messages at the core of thursday's
meeting in vatican city between the red
river metis delegation and pope francis
the pope asking for forgiveness and
expressing shame for the abuse and
lasting trauma inflicted by the
residential school system
david chartrand who accepted the apology
on behalf of the delegation calls it a
powerful start to healing although he
can't go back and change it
he understands the damage that was done
and he asked for me in that room and the
red river made he forgive him and the
church
so he took ownership of it a unique
papal visit as the delegation emphasized
the connection between the red river
metis and the catholic church we need to
overcome this pain and move forward
because we do need the church we need to
be able to connect spiritually two
survivors sharing personal stories of
the abuse they endured in catholic-run
residential and day schools highlighting
the role christianity plays in metis
communities and the need to restore
those broken bonds i have some very very
fond memories
as a child
going to church
and to going to the different seasonal
events through the church and following
the the word of the lord
that being said
we also suffered at the hands of
individuals who misappropriated
their
authority and abused the children
and that should not have never happened
the delegation presented the pope with
gifts including a beaded cross and
slippers signifying the need to walk
forward together we want them to walk
with us we want them to be with us we
want them to see and understand but to
support us as we go forward never give
up on us and we won't give up on them
pope francis has already committed
coming to canada in july while there's
no word on whether or not winnipeg will
be a stop on that trip the delegation is
hoping he'll come here to bless the
gravesite of may t leader louis riel
marty blount global news winnipeg
there is a 24-hour crisis line available
for anyone experiencing pain or distress
as a result of their or a loved one's
residential school experience the number
is toll-free 1-800-721-0066
prime minister justin trudeau met with
inuit leaders in ottawa today to
finalize a policy to recognize the
homeland of the inuit people inuit
nunegat comprises most of canada's north
and would be recognized as a distinct
geographical cultural and political
region
there will now be a foundation of
knowledge that we will expect from
federal departments and from those who
have to work on intuit issues or who
have inuit considerations in
their portfolios
and we can build upon that foundation
instead of start anew across all federal
departments
say this policy is transformative and
important to respecting inuit
self-determination and will affect
positive change for years to come
there are new developments tonight in
the investigation into the death of an
edmonton high school student karnvir
sahota was attacked at a bus stop on
april 8th and he died of his injuries a
week later police say seven young people
have been arrested and were initially
charged with attempted murder they will
now face upgraded charges since the boy
has died zahoda who was 16 was attacked
outside his high school while he was
waiting for a bus an autopsy completed
on wednesday determined he died from a
stab wound to his chest
there are thousands of people across
canada waiting for surgery right now the
system is backlogged because of covid19
which messed up schedules for just about
everything and hospitals already
operating at peak levels were
overwhelmed as jamie morocco reports
some canadians who can afford it have
chosen to get their surgery outside the
country paying big bucks to bypass long
wait times
patricia rush has no problem moving
through this springtime snow now but six
months ago the 60 year old could barely
limp the pain was excruciating when i
would walk a certain way i'd get this
sharp pain in my leg rush required a
total hip replacement before the
pandemic she was told the weight for her
surgery in alberta was 15 months once
covet hit the timeline only grew i had
to do something i am a very active
person and i had no life she found a
clinic a world away in lithuania the
wait time there just two to four weeks
for sixteen thousand dollars she booked
her flights surgery and rehabilitation
paying for procedures in foreign
countries has become increasingly
popular in the pandemic out of 46
countries the medical tourism
association ranked canada as the number
one surgical destination worldwide but
that's for private clinics only and the
prices here are steep that hip
replacement for example can cost upwards
of 30 thousand dollars in canada's
private system toronto emergency room dr
lisa salomon says those waiting on
canada's universal health care system
often pay their own price it does impact
their
their life and their
life expectancy last year canadians
faced a median wait time of just over 25
weeks between referral and receiving
treatment that's the longest wait time
ever recorded by the fraser institute
and a
175 percent increase from 30 years ago
when the average was just nine weeks
waiting on surgery for her hip maureen
johnston was told it would be up to two
years wanting to get back to her active
lifestyle sooner the 63-year-old retiree
opted to speed things up spending 14
thousand dollars and booking abroad it
dips into your retirement savings but
what's the point of having them if
you're living in pain
patricia rush can relate she's glad she
took her health into her own hands
because three years later she's still on
a canadian wait list i spoke to one of
my doctors and i said to him what do
people do when they're in this kind of
pain they must be suicidal and depressed
and he said absolutely both
a problem she worries is being swept
under the rug putting the lives of
canadians on hold and at risk jamie
morocco global news toronto
surgical backlogs are a problem across
the country tomorrow jamie looks at
solutions to tackle the long wait lists
and why some frontline staff say it's
time for hospitals to take matters into
their own hands
a canadian low-cost airline is making
some internal changes as it faces the
risk of having its license suspended
flair airlines says it's reducing the
level of u.s influence on its board of
directors reducing the share of seats
held by its miami-based business partner
the company is under review by the
canadian transportation agency a
preliminary hearing last month found the
edmonton-based airline may not meet
canadian ownership requirements to fly
in the country flare's ceo is dismissing
calls by two airline associations
representing air canada and westjet for
ottawa to reject its request for a
temporary exemption from canadian
ownership rules
these guys have been ripping off the
canadian public for decades for decades
you all know it
you'll sit there when i go out and
listen and talk to people everyone's
complaining about the duopoly so don't
be surprised that they get defensive
when a company that's genuinely
efficient at providing low-cost airfares
comes into the market
flair has until may 3 to respond to the
transportation agency's concerns
britain's prime minister and party gate
coming up the new investigation into
whether he misled parliament about
gatherings during lockdown
china's biggest city shanghai has
extended strict coveted 19 lockdown
measures a day after easing rules in
some districts cases are rising in areas
now outside the city not under
quarantine beijing insisted zero coveted
policy of strict lockdowns mass testing
and lengthy quarantines has kept deaths
low and avoided the public health crises
that engulfed much of the rest of the
world
and life in hong kong is slowly
returning to normal after that city
relaxed coven 19 restrictions that have
been in place for four months gyms
restaurants museums and disneyland are
open again this was the worst wave of
covet 19 in hong kong nearly 1.2 million
people are known to have been infected
since january
british prime minister boris johnson's
troubles aren't over he will face a
house of commons inquiry into whether he
lied to parliament about parties held at
10 downing street during lockdown in
2020
the question is as on the order papers
many of that opinion say i i
of the country no
i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it mps approved a motion
to launch the inquiry once the police
investigations into 12 gatherings at
downing street are finished johnson
who's on a trip to india had tried to
delay this vote some of his own mps say
he should resign earlier this week
johnson apologized in the house of
commons he says he has absolutely
nothing to hide johnson was fined for
breaching lockdown rules after telling
mps no rules had been broken
ahead a canadian artist's royal tribute
to the queen on her birthday
[Music]
well if you have a head for heights and
steep stairs this is for you london's
westminster abbey is allowing tourists
on the rooftop this summer for the first
time in its history it's a chance to see
the gothic architecture of the abbey up
close and get some great views of london
westminster abbey is where queen
elizabeth married and where her
coronation took place
70 years ago this year
it's hard to fathom how many world
leaders the queen has outlived and
outlasted over those 70 years and how
many people she's met today on her 96th
birthday redmond shannon has the story
of one canadian who met her as a boy and
has never forgotten what the monarch
means to him
[Music]
from birthday salutes and horse parades
in london
two birthday serenades in windsor the
queen herself marked the day much more
quietly flying off to sandringham estate
a favorite residence of her late husband
prince philip
and it's a charming touch that the queen
has decided to spend her 96th birthday
where
he used
to enjoy living on this birthday in her
platinum jubilee year the tributes keep
on coming from admirers everywhere i can
still remember their shimmering in her
mint outfit and her white hat with her
silver shovel it
was a lovely thing to see it was 1976
when owen grant innis saw the queen
plant a tree in halifax
the queen has always been an icon in my
life the canadian artist says being
young and gay in those days was
isolating but the queen always inspired
him and i think like every child our
world is very small
but through the queen i realized i was
part of something bigger when innis
recently became a dual british canadian
citizen he reflected again on what the
monarch means to him painting portraits
of a life of landmarks for a new book
the highs and the lows like the
difficult aftermath of princess diana's
death so what i see to you now as your
queen and as a grandmother
i say from my heart as your queen and as
a grandmother i say from my heart
and i think that was such an honest
moment and it connected with me in my
heart because i realized fully that her
principal concern was protecting her two
young boys in his holds out hope queen
elizabeth will receive the book he sent
it to the palace just in time for her
birthday the little five-year-old boy
who fell in love with his queen
it would make him very happy for her to
see this book because it was done in a
spirit of of love and gratitude redmond
shannon global news london
snacking for science next the
hard-hitting research to answer one
pressing cookie question
is it a bird is it a plane no it is a
potato shaped moon crossing the face of
the sun nasa's perseverance mars rover
captured phobos one of the red planets
two moons eclipsing the sun in early
april phobos is more than 150 times
smaller than earth's moon its transit
lasts just over 40 seconds much quicker
than the typical solar eclipse we see of
the earth's moon
people who like cookies and who doesn't
right
no there is more than one way to enjoy
them and when it comes to oreos there
has long been a tantalizing mystery why
you can't split an oreo evenly in half
well a team of engineers at mit is on
the case they've done extensive research
on why the oreos cream filling seems to
always stick to just one wafer yes it's
a real study published in a real journal
and everything mike drollet digs into
the results with his own sweet study on
how the cookie crumbles
the makers of the oreo cookie have made
it clear over the years if you separate
their cookie do it the right way please
don't fiddle with the oreo
a few years ago there was even a contest
to see if a robot could do it better
apparently that is a big deal for humans
it wasn't exactly a success and then six
months ago engineers at mit decided to
take a run at it with a twist lead
researcher crystal owens wanted to
challenge the oreo way as the only way i
feel like that's a debatable subject my
my preference i feel like the wafer on
its own is a little bit too dry so i
want to have like a little bit of cream
on both sides
they hoped they could make science fun
for kids by engineering the oreometer a
device they created to put the perfect
twist on a cookie alas they failed and
oreo traditionalists let them know
before i did this study i didn't know
those people existed but i feel like
they're just very they're very smug and
satisfied right now now if we were to
accept the mit premise that there needs
to be equal amounts of insides on each
wafer the global new science lab has
come up with a far more efficient method
take one cookie
separate
take a second cookie
separate
take the extra wafers
discard
voila
science
that's too much cream
perhaps but to do it her way wasn't
happening so in her conclusions she
offered the people at oreo a solution
put texture on the inside of the wafers
to grip the cream
they haven't called her back
oh and by the way many many oreos were
harmed during this report mike delay
global news toronto
i think he ate a couple that is global
national for this thursday i'm donna
freeze and we leave you tonight with a
giant ukrainian flag unfurled on the
macdonald bridge in halifax the gesture
of solidarity with ukraine it's the
first time a flag from another country
has flown on the bridge and it's
expected to stay there until russia's
war in ukraine ends
thanks for watching i'll see you on
saturday for the new reality bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you